hero before mocking farmersonly.com the
dating the dating site for country folks
or as I call it Hicks with dicks
you must remember it's better for rural
America to date on farmersonly.com than
where they used to date ancestry.com
new rule at this rich creep really
dressed as an old deaf woman to get away
with murder
HBO has to start hounding me so Okawa
the world's oldest woman because I'm
pretty sure she's Sheldon Adelson new
role since everyone else gets an award
show it's time we also had one for stock
photo models welcome to the 2015 stock
E's recognizing excellence in the field
of stock photo art this year's nominees
for stock photo model of the year are
Susan King for I hate my computer
Beverly Hanbury Tennyson for happy black
person and Barry Rogers jr. for my dick
doesn't work
knurl the makers of this fun inflatable
the makers of this fun inflatable slide
must apologize to these kids parents ah
they're supposed to be celebrating a
birthday
not reliving one
Neru let's call the Elton John Dolce &
Gabana feud what it is a face-off
between a classic old leathery bag doll
taken
you